what do you think has been the most
important hire of all the glue
that's really enabled the business to
push forward if that's a sales director
an ops director people manager like what
do you think
has been like and absolutely like
someone maybe you
could have gotten the business earlier
that you think they made an even more of
a difference what would you say
a sales director in the business earlier
would have made a huge difference
um in terms of scaling the business up
i think that would have been a critical
hire but i would say honestly
the critical hire was
i'm loath to say this in a recruitment
business but it was an accountant
it was sorting out it was sorting out
all of the um all of the mess that sales
people do because we're not experts at
that we don't really want to take care
of that stuff we want to do the exciting
stuff of selling and making money and
making a difference in people's lives
that's what we're brilliant at and
that's what we want to do and i think
the critical
hire was um those of you actually the
marketing director
because they helped us explore explode
our brand
and really take us on to the next level
it's very difficult to say
that one particular sales person was
[Music]
critical